Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Seth from San Diego. Seth,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Good morning, David. So a couple of
a couple quick question. No, Ari. So the first
one is, do you think in the election, liberals
should take more pride in being liberals? Because
it seems like a lot of these conservative ads have
like, I'm afraid, American versus conservative.
I'm a conservative and pro conservative come
conservative. Christian conservative. Yeah.
And you don't hear any of that being a liberal.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, you know, you sometimes do
see I sometimes see in ads, candidates will say
stuff like, I'm a proud Democrat and I find
it so stupid to be to be perfectly frank.
What I do think is that, listen, the country is
really on our side on the issues. When you look at
what is what is the view on abortion
that's most prevalent right now?
What's the view on gay marriage? What's the
view on whether we should tax the very rich
to fund social programs? It's the views
are of the progressives. The problem is
because the progressives. Don't own
it in the way that you're suggesting
it becomes disaggregated, where then the voters
don't realize you kind of really agree with the
progressives. And then it becomes this vicious
circle where people shy away from the labels and
then the voters are confused and then they think,
Oh, I should vote for a Republican. So I do agree
in general with the point you're bringing up.
Speaker 3: Okay. Because I'm not sure if you're
familiar who Bill Maher is, because that's
like my go to liberal right there, because
I feel like he's at the very he speaks like 90,
99% of my language. There's some stuff I called
him out on with. This is kind of stupid at times.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, Bill Maher, you know,
the thing about Bill Maher is he has
joined this contingent, which is like
the anti-woke free speech left, which is like
it's fine. I agree with Bill Maher about plenty,
but he's kind of fallen into this thing of
overstating the degree to which the so-called
woke left has taken over the movement, which I
think is a relatively small degree, actually.
Speaker 3: Exactly. Like he exaggerates that a
lot. Yes, I think because there is a, you know,
his new roles like. Yes, that he does. Yeah,
yeah. It's hilarious. But there's this,
you know, recent one that he was talking
about the conservatives and like,
you know, talking about how, you know, they
kind of put the positive and negative in
the same ad and he's doing all that. But I was
just wondering, is it do you think that is not
entirely smart because they want to see kind
of like B.D., you know, saying big. You know,
I'm not sure if I can curse on here, but.
Speaker 1: What you're saying is large
penis energy, this sort of like alpha.
Speaker 3: Males that, you know, big scientists
energy. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, that crap.
And so do you think there's not a lot of that from
the left? Because every time whenever a liberal is
here, you know, the country agrees. Liberals like,
for example, like, you know, this is my own
personal opinion. I'm not affiliating this with
anyone, but like I'm, you know, currently serving
the country right now. And this is my own personal
opinion, not of affiliating with anything.
Speaker 1: Oh, I gotcha. I agree with you. And
I think the best person so far, he has said it in
a direct way is actually Gavin Newsom, who in an
interview recently said, we need to be playing
offense, not defense, we need to be ruthless,
etc.. And it doesn't mean you have to agree with
him on policy, but he absolutely was completely
correct about what you're talking about.
Speaker 3: Exactly because I was on my phone and
like, oh, you're on CNN, you fricking liberal. And
I was like, Well, I don't watch Fox all the time,
you know? Right. Something like that. But like
they look at liberals as these nagging, you know,
wussy, you know, sissy like people. But, you
know, and most of the country agrees with them.
So when you hear conservatives like, oh, I'm,
you know, I'm a man or whatever the case may be,
which honestly, masculinity is actually
better than ever, which I don't know what the
hell they're talking about. Well, you know, I'm
sorry to drag this out for so long. I was this.
Speaker 1: Was stuff you really said at
all. And it's been a pleasure having you
on. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Of course.
And sorry to drag it out so long.
Speaker 1: No problem. You graduated there in San
Diego with a very powerful declaration. Uh, some
things we agreed on, some things that we did not.
Thank you to everyone I was able to
speak to that does it for calls today.
But there will be more opportunities, believe
me, folks. And then I hope to speak to you.